vous allez faire ah ouais je sais que
vous allez faire vous allez oust verser
un verre d'eau sur la tête en sang il
fait chaud avec cerise comme une bête
parce que c'est à titre de patrie qu'il
fait chaud est là elle a un truc à
chaque fois
je vais vous montrer je vais faire une
de leurs mines je vais vous montrer
l'attachement je vais beau mais il vrai
que vous êtes là vous me faites le pire
truc qui pensaient nous mettre de l'eau
sur la tête voiture frise prise comme
une match plein gré mine à la gueule toi
heureusement pour le ta gueule
exceptionnel c'est bon je vous la nulle
à la broche là
on savait c'était pour qu'ils votent agl
toi et jean-michel mais c'est jean
michel maire comme vous ne vous souvenez
pas du nom de chroniqueurs vous le
faites quand même eu chaud